accusing someone of narcissism has
become one of the great and tempting
insults of our age it's what we're
inclined to label anyone who appears
overweening boastful entitled or
excessively pleased with their own
existence but it's possible to wonder
whether the word really fits the
conceited and bombastic types we've
grown used to applying it to and a
larger point whether we're really
understanding and therefore correctly
addressing the origins of the
regrettable behavior to which it refers
behind our enthusiastic use of the term
lies an implicit theory of human nature
that people undue attention for
themselves grow pretentious and inclined
to bombast when at heart they feel an
extraordinary love for who they are it's
their hugely high estimation of
themselves combined with a reversed
pride and everything they are and do
it's at the root of their tendencies to
talk up their own achievements and to
try to secure the admiration of
strangers but on closer examination it
seems that the agitation and peacock
displays cannot really stand from a
feeling of being perfectly and required
ly enamored of Y itself those whom we
loosely call narcissists can't actually
think so well of themselves they boast
and show off because they can't find a
way of being sufficiently content with
who they really are and are driven on by
a manic haunting terror of their own
invisibility and mediocrity the
behaviors we associate with narcissism
the vanity the greed the lies they
aren't symptoms of self-love they are
proof of its dangerous
tragic absence let's recall the original
Greek myth from where the word descends
narcissus was a hunter from central
Greece the son of the river God's
Ephesus and the nymph liriope II he had
long flowing locks deep blue eyes
unblemished skin and full enchanting
lips one day as he
walks past a quiet pool of water he
caught sight of his own reflection
failed to recognize himself and was in
trance with the image he had never seen
anyone quite so enchanting and couldn't
stop falling profoundly in love with
himself the most admirable and rich in
being he'd ever spotted framed like this
narcissism sounds laughable and absurd
but derogatory remarks make us lose
sight of the genuine benefits of having
been able when young under the tutelage
of kindly caregivers properly to admire
oneself without reserve to have been
allowed to strut and sing and feel
utterly at home in one's own skin and
for a time delight amply in the sheer
wondrousness for one's own existence
there might be such a thing as good
narcissism a phase of coming to love
oneself that's the precondition for
knowing how to love anyone else most of
the problems of the world are created by
people who do not love themselves who
cannot inwardly believe in their own
Worth those who grew up with a searing
hatred and shame about who they were who
cannot now stop insistently claiming an
attention of which they were once
deprived one has to hate oneself really
rather a lot before it ever seems like a
good idea to devote one's life to trying
to prove valuable in the eyes of
complete strangers by contrast the
really self-contented ones among us are
those who have no burning need for
adulation and know how to draw quiet
satisfaction from nothing more than
their own unadorned ordinary being we
should want to build a world not where
there are fewer people who have loved
themselves but where there are many more
a world richer in what we can term
healthy narcissism we will be modest and
self-effacing ready to be quietly
interested in and attentive to others
happy to forego baubles and manic
acclaim once we've had a chance to gaze
at our own reflection for a while and
think it really pretty nice nice enough
for us then to go out and start
generously to
kindness and selflessness to those
around us did you know that the school
of life is actually a place ten places
in fact campuses all over the world from
Melbourne to London Taipei to Istanbul
with classes and books and lots more
please click on the link below to
explore more